Neville is in here small place wherever  we go to town of mobile gone I believe  we had a number one defense in the state  of Texas it's a good day to see that  colleges because English English coming  out of my dreams I didn't have any  officers at all nobody wanting me her to  my senior year so i had to triple myself  to go out there and so who I am improve  myself it's nice to know that you have a  way to go to college fifty parents  outside i sent to pay for college  football taught me this would be a man  take responsibility contains is always  going to join the player hate empty  stadium with a champion field i'm  excited with the overplay their my star  lon dr. Spencer odd oh he's always  fullest no matter what we played I'd be  saying this in the brought down when her  I can't predict the square but I just  know he's gonna come out on top